I actually am kind of surprised that
it's rotten I thought it was going to be
on the Fresh side just on the lower end
of the price
48 which I do not agree with
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
RT after show Quantum Mania is upon us
phase five of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has kicked off with two of the
mightiest tiniest Heroes Ant-Man and the
wasp in the new film Quantum Mania we
are here today to talk everything that
we saw in the movie it's a spoiler Heavy
after show as it always is around here
so if you've not yet seen the movie make
sure you go check it out get your
tickets come on back and join us when
you're ready to be spoiled with
everything that you saw in the movie
what we think could happen in the future
of the MCU and everything else in
between you may not want her to watch
this we had a deal
my name is Mark Ellis and joining me
today is one of my dear friends a
incredible movie reviewer on her own
YouTube channel the movie couple you can
also follow her on social media it's
Wendy Lee zany welcome to the after show
I I kind of want like an Applause sign
yeah studio audience like I'll do my own
I'm so excited to be here to talk about
Ant-Man and the WASP console Mania so
thank you for having me and doing this
like face to face in person which it's
great it's so much fun because we're
going to do a deep dive on the details
and answer some of the burning questions
that the movie left for us as these MCU
movies tend to do and so I just want to
kick off with a very simple general what
did you think of this movie that seems
to have a lot of audiences divided I
thought it was a lot of fun though there
is a lot going on and they really use
that like two hour and five minutes I
think to its fullest potential and to
the point where I feel like there is
a lot to take in but yet at the same
time I felt there could have been more
to be told so I felt like
some parts of me like I thought act one
really a lot of fun act two I felt we
were kind of in like a back and forth
situation and then we ramp it up with
with acts three so overall lots of fun
it's Wang versus Kang and there's a lot
of wanks and the kangs well there's
actually a lot of kangs too that we find
out in a post-credits scene so before we
get to all that I'll just let you all
know the Tomato Meter right now
scoreboard says it's the second rotten
film in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
just one percentage Point ahead of the
low bar for the MCU at least in terms of
Tomato Meter which is the eternals at 47
this is 48 but the audience score which
is verified this is every audience ever
actually paid to see the movie they say
84 so they're making it Super Fresh here
and the critics consensus on Rotten
Tomatoes currently reads Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania mostly lacks the
spark of fun that elevated earlier
Adventures but Jonathan majors's Kang is
a thrilling villain poised to alter the
course of the MCU so we talk about the
Tomato Meter score and we say oh well
it's a second MCU movie ever to be
rotten what's going on here what went
wrong 48 which I do not agree with I saw
when I saw the movie and I walked out of
the theater I saw okay
it would I actually am kind of surprised
that it's rotten I thought it was going
to be on the Fresh side just on the
lower end of the front I thought it
would be interested in the 60s exactly
store 11 Thunder 64 and by the way throw
11 Thunder it's the third lowest so so
64 to 48 and 47. that's a huge drop yeah
why is it so low do you think with the
critics but it rebounded so well with
the audiences I think for the audience
when they go in they're fans and and
they're not saying critics aren't fans
of Marvel stuff okay let's just put that
on there sure the Venn diagram overlaps
it overlaps like you can be a Critic and
you can be a fan of like all the MCU in
the comic book movies right but I think
for a lot of the fans they go in looking
for a good time they're excited to see
the first movie of phase five
um and I think a lot of them go into
this they love Ant-Man this is a first
and foremost another Ant-Man movie it's
not a King movie it's an Ant-Man movie
right so so uh I think they went in
they're like we're excited to see Paul
Rudd as Scott Lang we're going to see
more of the ant family we're gonna get
to see the quantum realm and all of that
is a lot of fun put together there's a
lot of comedy in there that kind of is
very similar to Ant-Man one and two so
it's not so different from its
predecessors at all and I feel like with
the critics we look at movies in a
slightly different way in a critical way
where you're looking at not just like
the pacing and you're having fun but
you're also looking at script writing
performance
CGI all of that and you're kind of
trying to wrap your head around that
sure so I think that's where the big
divide is yeah and and this movie also I
mean I think that audiences are
receptive like you said they're also
very excited but they're looking for
these for these individual things that
like you want to see what sort of a
presence Kang is going to be as possibly
the next big MCU Baddie you also want to
see how they're going to close out this
Trilogy because I think a lot of
audience members see themselves in at
least a member of the Wang Family
primarily Scott Lang or you know if you
have Ant-Man and you have the WASP it's
like oh I can I can trick myself and
still be a superhero I just think that's
a cool relatable sort of premise even if
we will probably never get to venture
into a Quantum realm in our lifetime
that was the other thing that I took
from this movie that I really enjoyed
was getting to just live in that tiny
tiny quark-filled world for the better
part of the run time I mean it felt like
if the Star Wars Cantina was just like
one stop in the mall this felt like the
whole town I mean everything you have
all these different weird creatures and
and friends and allies and enemies going
on so that was just kind of a new place
that I thought the film did well in
inundating us real quick as to how this
world Works what's going on there's a
struggle there's a rebellion against the
premise and I think a lot of people are
looking at this movie as feeling very
star warsy which has a huge Star Wars
fan myself that's not necessarily a bad
thing for me I agree with that I don't
think it's a bad thing either because
first this is the first time we've ever
gotten to see the quantum realm and I
think ever since Ant-Man won we've been
very curious about like what is that
going to look like because all you see
them is shrinking down shrinking down
but you never got to be in it Janet
didn't want to talk about it ever so we
only well we only got her back in the
second movie but so you're curious
you're like how is this world and I
think in all of our heads because of how
little we know none of us knew was going
to be so full of life and like citizens
like Quantum people like Cassie said
um so that introduction had to come very
fast because you're not dealing with
just like the first movie okay great
Ant-Man Hank Pym Scott Lang second movie
okay Scott Lang hope Pym right and ghost
and then now this one we've multiplied
now we've got five family members plus
the quantum people plus king plus Modoc
and I think that's where it got it felt
a little congested and they needed to do
had to have the explanation of like how
this world is going to look and live and
the citizen and why are there Rebellion
Fighters and it was so much cramped into
that second act that's a lot that I was
just like wait hold on like we need I
need more sort of uh where why the
console people are fighting why why does
this Janet name when you said it was you
know her what gentura heard right she's
like Janet and I was like oh like I
wanted more history of that and I wonder
I still wonder now like what could I
have swapped out to give us a more
fulfilling more full story I think one
of the one of the big story points in
here that hit home with a lot of critics
and audiences was that interaction
between Janet and Kang they were sort of
flashing back which I love that's what
the movie opens and I think a lot of
people responded to that because we're
getting to see a sympathetic version of
this villain or at least that's the the
person that he's putting forth to Janet
were you like oh no this this poor guy
world is stuck in this Quantum realm how
is he going to get out to get back to
his people and now we find out that time
it's not really important or relevant
Kang is not a guy that worries about
being anywhere on time because time is
just this little thing to him but that's
also where he's in the quantum realm and
he doesn't have full use of his powers
and so the Kang aspect of this we might
have gone in thinking this is going to
be like a fun family adventure and
another Ant-Man rap we walked out saying
okay what everything about the movie
Jonathan Majors his performance as this
Kang yeah has many kangs was the star of
the movie absolutely I think ever since
I saw him in Lovecraft country I was
like I was like oh this man I can't wait
to see him in more things and he's gone
on to you know creep threes coming out
devotions out he is king So we already
saw a sneak peek of what potentially
King could be in Loki season one when he
played uh he who remains so I've been
very excited for him to get to play King
the Conqueror and like so far we haven't
really gotten to see him as a villain
Jonathan Majors sure it's it's mostly
been hero so I've been really excited
even like he who remains it's like yes
villain but at the same time it's kind
of like toes on that line of like yes
but not really but came to conqueror is
intimidating and threatening you got a
real good taste of like what he could do
with a snap of his fingers literally and
again this is the king that a lot of so
the post-credits scene is is we just see
a bunch of kangs and they're all ready
to go you know it's a battle they're
like oh The One That Got Away sort of
the one Rogue Kang was the one that we
were focusing on in this movie and so
while they look at him as being very
strong I think that he was weakened by
his powers being in the quantum realm so
maybe that's an explanation that for I
think a plot point that a lot of fans
have an issue with which is okay wait so
this guy's carrying conquer and they're
setting up the next three or four years
of this MCU to be the Kang Dynasty and
the dude just got felt by ants like what
are we looking at here do you see that
as being just a reflection of him being
weaker or was that just something that
you felt the movie didn't really handle
all that well was how this came got
defeated I don't necessarily feel like
he is weaker I felt like
it may have to do with the way they
wrote they wrote that where he's
supposed to be this super threatening
being uh and sure he may not be in his
full power full Kang in the quantum
realm but regardless he's still Kane
going up against Ant-Man and he already
said he's like oh you're an Avenger I've
killed one before which one are you the
one with the hammer so you know he's run
in to Thor he's seen this you've seen
people like this many times and usually
comes out on top yeah so he's not even a
little bit phased by that like he was
just so stoic and blank when he heard
the Avengers where Scott said like a
threat you know to intimidate and he's
like I don't I don't even care so at the
end when he was sort of be granted it
took a whole group effort of the entire
Quantum people and man plus the WASP
there's a family effort and a rebellion
but I think that people look at Ant-Man
and this being the third movie and
saying okay look we've seen a lot of
great trilogies before you gotta off
somebody I was kind of like emotionally
prepared to lose either Michael Douglas
or Michelle Pfeiffer I'm like oh not
hanker Janet but like maybe one of them
goes we can't God forbid anything
happens to Cassie it's not gonna be
Ant-Man is it's not going to be wasp is
it and it ended up being no everybody's
okay everybody's okay which is that kind
of a downer I mean I mean it's an upper
because like everybody survived but I
think sometimes people look for that
emotional like that pull you know that
Force awakens Han Solo oh my God we lost
him is that something that was missing
from here did it need to be in there
like did the stakes need to feel higher
and maybe that being the result of a
family member dying I think for me
specifically I think I was looking for a
little bit of that that loss to serve as
a motivation to move forward regardless
of who it was that was going to
um potentially face a hero's death sure
and can also be Kang showing his lack of
sympathy and and more of a display of
his powers and he fights Ant-Man yeah
but it doesn't go out the way that I
think a lot of Vegas prognosticators
would have bet that Ant-Man is able to
defeat Pang again with the help of an
army advance and a rebellion going on
yeah there's a lot going on and look
when in the trailer I think this is
where like the idea was kind of born in
my head selling my own headcanon I
thought maybe we're going to see a
hero's death was because I don't have to
win we just both have to lose and I love
that great line and so this is a this is
a man who has lost a lot of time with
his daughter
um and has it all back right now like
feeling he's wrote a book he's on a
podcast it's great
um and to sacrifice it all to save the
family and the rest of his people and
and whatnot and I really thought we were
going to be able to see the sacrifice
that so when we move forward to the next
chapter and when we move back around to
King again it's going to give hope and
Cassie and Hank and Janet more of them
and even the quantum people like more
motivation to be like we got we gotta
band together and defeat this guy so for
it to not happen again this is my own
fault for thinking this way I literally
built my own head can I was like oh this
gonna happen well we've been trained as
as audience members for you know the
decades we've been going to the movies
where it's like you just kind of you
feel a little different in your body and
you're eating that popcorn a little
faster because you're just so
anticipating and concerned about
somebody you've been going to see at the
movies for years not making it out of a
film alive we didn't get that here right
yet anyway but I mean phase five it
ain't gonna work out well for everyone
yeah and so we have Kang presented as
this big Baddie and we'll get into the
post credit scenes in just a little bit
but there was another you know Nemesis
in this film and it was a nemesis from
way back in ant-man's past and now it
seems like this Nemesis has become
somewhat divisive when the fans react to
sing modak this version of Modoc anyway
which is actually lo and behold Corey
Stahl playing Darren the bad guy from
the first Ant-Man now he's back in this
very weird Square form where he feels
like just the Ultimate Weapon of death
but inside maybe there is a little bit
of humanity left I okay so on paper uh
when I saw it in the trailer was
revealed the big floating face
um which I didn't even catch on the
first watch through uh in the trailer so
on the second watch I was like wait
whose face is that it actually took a
second because they took Corey's face
and they kind of had to stretch it a
certain way oh if you just showed that
picture to me I would not have been able
to tell you that's worse than a DMV
photo so you know uh so and I went oh
this is the angle they're going to
approach Modoc and I took a step back
and I went yeah you know that can be
kind of cool to kind of a full circle
moment for Darren back into Ant-Man one
to Loop all three movies together like
it's not really the Modoc that like I
have heard about and I have like watched
and read about but sure like let's let's
see let's see how it was and I felt like
they got a lot of the personalities and
I thought the look of Modoc with the
thingy on yeah I didn't mind it I
actually liked it but it was when they
flipped to Darren's face that I often it
took me out a little bit
I have like a love hate with this
version of Modoc because there's so many
funny moments right and it felt like
that's why Modoc was in this movie less
to be that weapon of death and more just
to get some Chuckles that the MCU is
known for because it's gonna be less
laps once we get into the quantum realm
with the Lang found because they're just
trying to figure out what's up and
what's down this Rebellion not a lot of
Chuckles happening there we get a scene
with Bill Murray intimating that maybe
some stuff between him and Michelle
Pfeiffer went down in the quantum realm
in years past but that's really it and
then Modoc shows up so I appreciated
just the laughs and the lightness that
we got in contrast to all of the real
Hard Scrabble stuff that Kang is
spouting and that this Rebellion is
going through but I can see where people
were let down by it not being quote
their Modoc so what what's the version
of Modoc that you would want to have
seen in Ant-Man I wanted the ones from
the comics like I don't have a deep dive
on Modoc like when I did talk to Shep
about it he would explain to me yeah
like he loved it he had all these Modoc
things he always said you're a great pal
judge that the best the best so uh I was
kind of and plus there's the Hulu um
series Modoc so I was kind of expecting
something similar to that version so
when they kind of like switched the
angle to make it be Darren like on paper
again I thought it was great but I felt
like the personality was so off and now
we see that we know that Modoc didn't
make it out of the quantum realm in my
head I'm like oh so
are we going to be able to get another
one because I feel like they're going to
bring aim into
the equation so but I don't know like I
mean this is the beginning of phase five
I'm gonna let Marvel do its thing and
figure it out because now we have movies
and TV shows so there's a lot of
different ways to introduce
I don't know if we're going to get
another Moda but you know there's a lot
of ways to introduce new characters or
characters from a different realm and I
mean that's I think that the thing that
I really appreciate about this movie was
that it felt like we hit a soft reset of
where we were in phase four because just
me personally I felt like I loved the
first three phases of the MCU and then
phase four felt like okay I just had a
great party in Vegas and then phase four
is me waking up the next day and being
like all right let me just get my
bearings here and I'm not really
following what the hell is the
Multiverse about I think we really came
together at the end with black panther
wakanda forever but I I was a little
done with using the the Multiverse as
just a way to get some famous characters
and some cool cameos so I appreciate it
going from that into the quantum realm
now the two can go hand in hand a little
bit like when Kang is saying I've met
people like you before I've killed many
Avengers in other Realms but just being
in the quantum remote feel like this is
cool this is much more fun for me anyway
and it feels much more meaningful it's
been just being in another Multiverse
where if these events don't work out the
way we hope well we still have our
normal planet Earth that we can just
always go back to and one of the the
real selling points of the film walking
out for me was that family dynamic
between the legs and particularly
between Scott and his daughter then he
got Grandma and Grandpa for kicking some
ass too so it was a real Family Affair
and I think that's why a lot of
audiences are giving at such a high
rating I agree with that it's first and
foremost an Ant-Man 3 movie which like
again we've touched on this already like
I in my head fell too victim to my own
head Cannon and I was like this is gonna
be like Infinity war end game like I
really sought it in halfway not halfway
through it was way earlier than that but
I was like you gotta remember this as an
Ant-Man once you saw Scott back at
Baskin Robbins yeah exactly we might not
get everything in this one movie Ant-Man
yeah so uh that was kind of my my own
fault for it I just got too excited
about the the premise of King and not
realizing well realizing but not at the
same time that we can't go full out in
the first movie of phase five you gotta
build up to it like that's not how
Thanos was done like how many times did
we see Thanos in post-credit scenes and
teased before we finally got that so we
gotta build it all back up so I feel
like with phase four it was it served as
like here are some new Avengers to pay
attention to Chang Chi
um here is like the next phrase for
where Thor is in his life and and you
know we also have a couple of Disney
Plus shows Miss Marvel Etc to kind of
loop it all in together this is all
setting it up for when we get to the end
of phase five where we're going to be
and then you know all of phase six and
you use the word Setup movie and I think
that that's just it gets an e-jerk
reaction from a lot of people but I
always tell folks like like you know
what you're buying a ticket to you buy a
ticket to a movie called cocaine bear
guess what probably gonna see a bear do
a lot of blow all right you buy a ticket
to Creed Three you're gonna see two guys
in a ring punching each other a lot
right know what you're buying a ticket
to so with the Marvel Cinematic Universe
by this point this is there are over 30
movies deep and they have it plans for
at least 40 movies you know that these
films are going to set each other up
like I remember leaving a Maze Runner
movie back in the day and feeling like I
just wasted two hours not because the
movie was terrible but because the end
just felt like oh it's like come back
next next year because then then the
action really starts to ramp up and it's
like that was a whole setup movie I
didn't need that yeah but with this you
see the post-credits scene and you see
all the kangs they're talking like oh
yeah the one just lost yeah whatever
we're a bunch of kegs we can take on
anybody yeah did it feel empty to you
the movie you just saw because now we
have that reveal because for me I was
like I that's what this movie was
supposed to do it was just supposed to
set us up give us a little taste of how
akang operates yeah and then show us the
full might of this Kang Army so I left
the theater really excited for the
future with that post-credits scene what
was your take on that one and also the
one very that was just buried way down
at the end where we got to see Loki and
we got to see Owen Wilson in the
audience watching Kang on stage so the
first one I was really excited for
because I think a lot of people fans
were speculating are we going to get to
see the Council of King yeah and we sure
do at the end and it's it's just like
very impressive at all the costumes and
the different looks and the designs of
King and then you also realize this like
how are they with all the Avengers young
original whoever how are they going to
be able to beat this this Council of
Cain I don't know you you take care of
one yeah and there's another one they
just they just keep popping up but it's
like you kill one and then like then you
have a whole account so like I remember
seeing Thanos in post-credit scenes and
being like e this is going to be a tough
it's like I don't want to be in your
position so yeah it's it's going to be
insane which is why I really did enjoy
that that post practice seeing plus it
was literally just out of like the panel
the comic book it was almost identical
so I enjoyed seeing that and then the
deep deep one way past the credits uh is
it's like a nice little Stinger for Loki
season two very excited because we
already know that him and Sylvie got to
meet King uh he who shall remain and oh
he who remains and now he is trying to
be like I gotta get back to like my
timeline nobody here knows me morbius is
like who are you it's really different
so they're on the search of this new guy
and we get to see Victor timely which I
don't know much about but what I
remember at the both times that I saw
Ant-Man 3 was the cheer from the crowd
and they were so loud that I literally
could not hear wonton Hiddleston was
saying and I was like what did he say so
I think it's like are you sure this is
the guy yeah that's the guy I'm sure and
it's just another fun way to see what
iteration of King we're gonna get and
how different they all look and what
kind of motivation this king is going to
have you know as hearing you explain it
what he just did was was you know
eye-opening for me because I'm starting
to think of these movies as just giant
trailers and I don't mean that to slight
them right but I think that's why you
see such a discrepancy between the
Tomato Meter and the verified audience
score is like we see a movie trailer
there's a reason why movie trailers
aren't reviewed you know because it's
like we react to him it's like oh that
was awesome I can't wait to see that I
think a lot of fans like you and me we
see a full movie but we're like oh
that's gonna be something going for
forward and oh did you see that nugget
that's going to come back we got all
these kangs what what does that mean for
the dynasty going forward where I think
if you're watching it just with the
critical eye you're like okay that's all
well and good what was the movie that I
just watched right and that was Ant-Man
of the WASP Quantum Mania family
adventure cool villainous presence some
laughs maybe too many or maybe
characters misused for laugh purposes in
some people's eyes but when you look at
just Ant-Man and and the WASP Quantum
made it's a very hard I'm just going to
say it man three when you look at
Ant-Man three just as the whole just as
that and you're not really looking too
far to the Future and what this movie is
setting up it still had a job to do as a
film on its own where do you think it
ranks in the pantheon of MCU films this
is going to be in your top half or
closer to your bottom half to rank this
movie that's gonna be hard uh it's not
my favorite Marvel movie so if you were
if I were to like just split it sure
half and half not any placement top or
bottom I would put on the second half
um like I had fun with it and I
understand the purpose of serves I was
more entertained by other Marvel titles
what are you most excited about going
forward then so if we look at this movie
and I think we will look back on this
movie as maybe not a misfire but a
stepping stone to something really
really cool I mean and there's a lot of
titles that Marvel introduced at last
year's Comic Con where we're like oh my
God look at this slate this looks
amazing just leading up to movies called
The Gang Dynasty I mean before you even
get that we get new Captain America get
a blade I mean there's a lot of stuff to
look forward to what are you most
excited about in Phase five going
forward
uh well obviously more of the King right
uh I am I've been saying this for years
and I just don't know when we're gonna
get it I don't think we're getting into
phase six but um Fantastic Four X-Men
yeah I see a lot of comments saying
where's doctor doing why can't we get Dr
Doom in this thing you got to give it
you got to give it time okay you can't
you can't just jump in like that that's
why that's why this first king like
people were like oh he was defeated it's
like well you can't ha you can't give
the big bad like a home run out the out
I'm not saying a huge they should always
be defeated but there should be some
sort of a build up to a story and In
fairness it was a lot of dance it was a
lot it was a crap ton of ads you know
what I would love uh I know that they
built out Cassie to be stature as we can
tell already
um so I'm excited for the premise of the
Young Avengers
um I love to see more of the ant family
if they keep off like everybody in I
would not mind Janet and Hank like
having suits oh wouldn't that be I I was
so happy that they didn't die in this
movie because I was I was prepared for
it because again you've been trained as
cinephiles to to expect something like
that coming but with the backstory of
Janet and her adventures in the quantum
realm I thought that that was so and the
pain that she's been harboring back on
Earth thinking about all the guilt that
she's been feeling like she's like we do
not talk about this
um you may want to know what your
granddaughter's up to if you continue to
withhold information because man are
they messing with some stuff so
communication it's hard in families and
this isn't the most functional family
we've ever seen so I understand why
maybe not everything was on the table
but seeing a future Wang really embraced
that role of a hero and sort of
reinvigorate her dad to Don the suit and
not just be an Avenger in name and with
your history but with actually
continuing to be a superhero defending
Earth and the known universe I thought
those story lines really played well in
this movie yeah I felt like out of uh
aside from Janet and Kang I really enjoy
the interaction between Cassie and Scott
like they bought it they bought it heads
as you would with a teenage daughter but
they also gave each other that room to
kind of have like the conversation and
and figure each other out and you know
Scott's feeling guilty about losing all
those years and and Cassie's trying to
just do her thing so like I feel like a
lot of people are like oh things came
easily for her in the movie and I
actually don't agree with it I felt like
she had her fair amount of trial and
error you know yeah and she wasn't just
like going to protest she was like yeah
she was taking classes she was training
I mean there's there's a bar to get over
if you're a superhero you got to put
that stuff into practice at some point
so yeah Quantum realm you're you're
getting thrown into the fire but that's
how you test gold I think another thing
with Cassie I would have and this kind
of brings back Modoc uh into the picture
when she delivers the don't be a dick
which got so many laughs uh from the fan
screen I went to and I get a funny line
like don't know don't be a dick and I
feel like because of the history Darren
and Cassie Hass years ago when he like
attacked her in the bedroom
um that could have filled out a nice
conversation between the two of them so
that final line of like don't be a dick
yeah that would have really hit home for
him be like okay because they have that
history and all that time that she you
know was spending basically uh being
captured
could have had like a little bit of
conversation with with Modoc because I
feel like the Modoc struggle was like
I'm no longer a Darren I don't have a
sense of myself I am just Modoc but
where I feel like deep down she could
have been that threat of connection to
be like you can still be Darren even
though you're in this form right and I
did like that they mentioned that you
know she was just a little girl when the
events of the first Ant-Man happened and
like you're never going to be a normal
family right if something like that
happens to you and so this is the path
that was sort of predetermined for me
because I didn't have a chance I was too
young to do anything about it here we
are and we have a new ass kicker in the
MCU courtesy of it so as a whole you
seem like you're maybe not thrilled with
this movie necessarily you liked it yes
but so you'll give it a fresh rating but
it's not one of your favorite in the MCU
but you seem pretty positive on where
this whole thing is going as we careen
towards 33 or 34 and 35 movies I feel
like Marvel has put out so many great
titles and
even if you take a look at some of the
titles before and again before infinity
War like you know not all of them are
are our home run and that's okay uh and
I and I feel like this is kind of where
we are because we got to the end of end
game and that was a close-up the first
chapter for that very long first chapter
very long chapter and so we can't just
go ham for every single movie for it to
have that level that end game level
without
creating arcs for these characters
building out their story introducing
there's like a lot to do and so I am
going to be patient I'm going to stick
with Marvel because I have a good time
watching their shows and I have a good
time watching their movies and you know
like you reference the shows a lot of
fertile soil there to grow you know
future Heroes villains and also story
points so you would recommend and I
think I would too like if you really
want to keep up with where the MCU is
going in the films is stick close to the
TV shows as well like they really
they're starting to go more hand in hand
yeah they're starting to I mean if if
anything like with especially I think
Miss Marvel how that's really going to
um be a really nice precursor to watch
before you watch the Marvels and then we
can kind of go all the way back to Wanda
Vision because we'd get to see Monica in
that as well so there's yeah so for
people who have time uh if you want to
dive into I think Loki is going to be a
super important watch but I think most
people have watched it the Marvels
um so Miss Marvel to watch and
yeah I just like and even Moon night
like I'm I'm curious as to because he's
such a cool character do we get that but
on film
that'd be great right and and you
mentioned if you have the time to watch
the show I know it's a lot of content to
check out the time isn't anything that
Kang or myself is really concerned about
because back when I was a kid you know
what we had nothing but time and we got
like one comic book movie every three
years we're like man I hope Batman
Forever is good I hope spawn is great
because we're not getting another one
for a while now we get a new either show
or movie something just about every week
it feels like so it's a lot of content
we are spoiled in today's day and age
but we can still find time to talk about
this stuff and do a deep dive like what
we do here on after show so hope you all
got a lot out of that and Wendy thank
you so much for your expertise and and
lending it to the studio here today
because Lord knows I need it to just
disseminate everything that happened in
the first four phases and now where
we're looking to the future of phase
five uh where can everybody out there
find you oh thank you so much for having
me this was such a fun conversation you
can find me everywhere on the social
medias I went to these zany or on
YouTube at the movie couple it's a and I
know you're doing a lot of writing now
too you're just really a Swiss army
knife when it comes to movies dissecting
them loving them going to watch them
going to a lot of screenings and stuff
so thanks for putting in the effort it
makes all of us smarter for the process
and as far as stuff for here at Rotten
Tomatoes we love doing the after show
it's always spoiler heavy see the movie
come on join us here at the after show
and rottentomatoes.com that's where you
can go to get a little look into all the
TV and movies that the MCU and its
future hold for you me I'm Mark Ellis
you can find me on social media at Mark
Ellis live stand up tour dates at
markellis.live and we will see you next
time right here on the RT after show
thank you